insects are a common fear among humans
evolutionarily certain bugs are
notorious for spreading diseases and in
some cases even being deadly arachnids
like the brown recluse and the brazilian
wandering spider hold venoms that are
extremely painful or deadly in high
enough dosages wasps and hornets exist
to defend their territory and sting
anything that gets close to them
mosquitoes have been responsible for
spreading diseases throughout history
yellow fever malaria zika virus and west
nile virus to name a few however what's
less commonly discussed are ticks they
are similar to mosquitoes they latch on
to mammals and consume their blood by
use of a thin needle-like mouth they are
also responsible for countless diseases
the most infamous being lyme disease
these animals are parasitic in nature
and depend on mammals like humans for
sustenance human beings are social
creatures and because of our behavior
it's been made pretty easy for us to
make friends find relationships connect
with our parents or do well in the
workplace the ability for humans to find
these connections so easily allowed us
to become the dominant species on earth
without this ability human beings would
not be in the place we are currently
today you may have gone out with a few
friends spoke to your loved ones or said
hi to someone on the street imagine if
these attempts to continue human
connection were instead met with silence
blank stares and disgust while in the
world of the scp foundation this fantasy
is a reality for a few unlucky people
who ran into some uncontained anomalies
before the scp foundation could properly
intervene it was a mild breezy summer
day perfect for a picnic or relaxing
outside with a refreshing beverage the
weather was ideal and daniel arnoldson
was up bright and early hoping to take
full advantage of it it had been weeks
of what felt like an infinite heat wave
making long periods of daylight
unbearable so daniel and his wife eliza
were itching to get a nice day outside
and now it came after going over some
ideas they decided on taking a nice hike
through the nearby trail in the
mountains they began packing their
backpacks bear spray granola water and
rain clothes in case this weather turned
its back on the people who were basking
in its glory they also brought some
picnic supplies for when they reached
the summit of the mountain the car ride
to the hiking trail was uneventful but
the couple was happy they were the
epitome of high school sweethearts the
two had been dating since their freshman
year of high school and it was
practically love at first sight dan and
eliza were almost inseparable they spent
every hour with each other and never got
bored of each other's presence they went
to every school dance together and even
wore matching outfits every time oh
how cute right there was always
something to talk about always something
to laugh about and they never even had a
real argument they went to the same
college to stay close and got married
right after graduation it was meant to
be dan and eliza were seemingly perfect
together in every way and to be out of
the house with bearable weather was
making them even more happy they arrived
at the start of the trail and began
their trek in the beautiful weather it
was long and it was tiring but with each
other at their sides they encouraged
themselves to finish it and have their
picnic eventually they made it to the
top dan who was more tired than eliza
left picnic setup duties to her and took
a seat in the grass his exhaustion got
the better of him and he laid down it
seems the couple forgot one important
item
bug repellent i guess they're not so
perfect after all huh as soon as daniel
laid himself onto the grass a small
almost invisible tick latched itself
onto the back of his neck he didn't
notice it and sat up as soon as the
picnic mat was placed down and moved
onto it they shared a nice meal and sat
for some time as the sun began to set
the couple made their way back down the
mountain and returned home now with
their new unknown visitor the tick the
next morning something changed in eliza
it was a monday so daniel had to get up
early for work normally he's met with a
groggy kiss and a sluggish good morning
from his wife but this day he didn't get
that dan brushed it off as she was
probably just tired from the hike he
thought to himself and headed to work
the day went by the same as most work
days putting in the hours excited to get
back home to his lovely wife for a nice
evening of netflix and chill but he
returned to something he never expected
to see as he pulled into his driveway he
saw all of his belongings shirts pants
shoes books pieces of technology even
the gifts he bought for eliza all left
in a heaping pile on the pavement
outside of their house he was appalled
his heart began to race as questions
flooded his mind did did i do something
wrong did i say something hurtful i
thought she had a good time yesterday
what happened he frantically barged into
the house and immediately yelled for his
wife eliza but there was no response
eliza he cried again but to no avail
either she wasn't home or he was being
completely ignored he ventured through
the many rooms of his home looking for
any sign of his wife dan found her in
her office and said her name to her
again eliza no response she didn't even
look at him what's going on eliza why
aren't you talking to me he yelled at
her no response he pushed eliza's desk
out of the way and stood in front of her
but was met with a blank forward-facing
stare
nothing she didn't even seem to see him
daniel went to touch his wife's shoulder
and upon contact her face turned to
disgust and she recoiled but she still
didn't look at him for the next five
hours daniel tried his hardest to get
the smallest amount of acknowledgement
from his wife but all he was met with
was silence blank stares and a face of
disgust whenever he went to touch her
day turned to night as daniel's pleas to
his wife continued it went on for so
long that a nearby neighbor called the
police and daniel was arrested and
placed in a criminal psychiatric ward
for the time he stayed there for a few
days as police interviewed eliza they
asked her a number of questions
regarding daniel but she didn't even
know who daniel was she was shown
pictures of them together but there was
no sign of recognition from her she
couldn't even see him in the pictures
that is when the scp foundation agents
embedded in the local law enforcement
sniffed out that there was a potential
anomaly involved in this event the scp
foundation agents wrangled oversight
away from the original police officers
and began their investigation they
interviewed daniel where he told them
the story of the hike and about the day
after it the scp foundation researchers
still posing as police and medical
professionals were stumped what could
cause such a loving couple to detach
from one another like that and why was
eliza acting as if she couldn't even see
daniel after a medical examination the
tick dan had been bitten by during the
hike was found to be still attached to
him it was removed and daniel was
allowed to go free from the psychiatric
ward sadly daniel went missing the next
day the following note was found in the
diary he began writing in since the
start of the event all alone always
alone she couldn't see me no matter what
i did she couldn't care
i i thought we were happy and one day i
come back home and all of my stuff is
out on the pavement when i go inside she
acts like i don't even exist i shout at
her and i shake her but nothing works
she just walks around me like i'm not
there
i scream at her for hours hours and she
just ignores me every time i touch her
she gets that disgusted look on her face
like i'm some scum so i took it off
forever she's a backstabber and a liar
she had it coming she got what she
deserved why didn't she just love me
anymore daniel was just as confused as
the scp foundation he lost his
relationship the love of his life for no
reason and now he can't even talk to her
as he's just met with silence and a
blank stare there was seemingly no
answer and the scp foundation
researchers were lost as to where to
start after a few days of scratching
their heads researchers recalled the
tick they removed from daniel's neck as
weird and as entertaining a tick as the
possible culprit of a bad breakup may
seem remember this is the scp foundation
and they have people running around in
there obsessed with the idea of eating
bread in hopes to poop out toast because
they think they're a toaster for 343's
sake
anyway back to the tech the scp
foundation began testing on it and just
as their hunch suggested it turned out
that it was far from a common tick it
merely resembled one the tick is now
designated
scp-1655 foundation also found something
incredibly peculiar
scp-1655 does not follow the common life
cycle of a normal tick and it does not
require the normal sustenance a
non-anomalous tick of its species would
need to survive they found the specimen
to be extremely aggressive it will
immediately target the nearest mammal
whether it be a small animal or a
full-grown human
scp-1655 will latch itself onto their
body and begin drawing blood given how
dangerous this anomaly could be if not
properly contained within safe
parameters the scp foundation assigned
it to the euclid level of containment
classes to ensure that
scp-1655 does not attach itself to any
one of real importance at the scp
foundation the following containment
procedures were devised
scp-1655 will be kept in a 5 by 5 by 5
centimeter plexiglass container
importantly any handling of scp-16
that requires the opening of its
container is to be performed by d-class
personnel only guess that d does really
stand for disposable huh while the
foundation suspected
scp-1655 as being the culprit for the
seemingly anomalous effects that ended
with daniel and eliza breaking up they
needed to run some tests to be sure that
scp-1655 was in fact the danger they
thought it was the first test began with
a female tabby cat and its kitten the
kitten was placed in its own chamber
with scp-1655
in mere seconds the tick latched on to
the young cat the kitten was then placed
in the same testing chamber as its
mother and the mother cat no longer
acknowledged the kitten's existence the
kitten meowed and cried for its mother's
attention however no signs of
recognition were observed from the
mother cat later the kittens attempts to
feed from its mother were also met with
resistance because of this the kitten
was not able to get enough sustenance
and thus starve to death researchers
also found another odd feature about
scp-1655
a viscous plasma-like substance appeared
in
scp-1655's blood sac another test was
conducted this time on a d-class subject
scp-1655 was introduced to d-236
after a period of a few hours d-236 was
asked to contact his grandmother who
raised him from the age of five years
old and on when on the phone d-236's
grandmother did not appear to recognize
or even hear d-236's voice the
overseeing researcher then took the
phone and began to question d-236's
grandmother about d-236
the old woman didn't understand what the
researcher was talking about and had no
memories of d-236
scp foundation researchers then assigned
a meeting between d-236 and his
grandmother upon meeting the old woman
showed no sign of acknowledgement
towards her grandson a researcher asked
d236 to touch his grandmother on the arm
he reached out toward her and she
immediately recoiled with a look of
disdain on her face but looking right
through him what do you feel ma'am a
researcher asked the old woman i don't
know it's like something spooky or
something over the period of the meeting
d-236 grew extremely emotionally
distressed and had to be removed from
the meeting location notably scp-1654
appeared engorged following this meeting
as if it was filled with blood from
these tests the scp foundation and its
researchers were able to devise the
following list of phenomenon that will
occur when
scp-1655 latches to a subject number one
any living being the affected subject
held any degree of affection for will
immediately lose all memory of the
subject's existence this includes minor
interactions to lifelong relationships
the people who once knew the victim will
also be unable to create or acquire any
new memories concerning the victim or
anything surrounding them number two
people who are once connected to the
subject will not be able to sense the
victim of
scp-1655 in any manner no matter the
circumstance however any physical
contact with the victim of
scp-1655 will cause mild discomfort and
disgust if the physical contact is left
for a prolonged period of time
discomfort and disgust will increase in
intensity the longer contact is held
until the physical contact is removed
number three if the subject begins to
feel affection for any other living
being including animals or other humans
they will also be affected by scp-16
and its anomalous properties scp
foundation researchers hypothesized that
scp-1655 is able to extract information
from its victims in turn
scp-1655 has the ability to alter its
effects thus allowing it to maintain
complete emotional isolation on its
victims and in turn feed on more of
these negative emotions that it causes
its victims to have number four the
subject will ignore scp-1655's
existence possibly the most important
detail of the scp foundation's findings
are about the lingering effects of
scp-1655
even after it was removed from a victim
it was found that these effects of being
unable to create human connections
remain permanent well after removal
however anyone the victim is not
affectionate towards is not affected by
scp-1655's effects but if that
connection is made the victim
practically does not exist to that
person scp foundation researchers
hypothesized that the parasite keeps a
mental link with its victims it then
continues to feed off of the negative
emotions the effects of its bite has
placed on the victim
it makes sense why the scp foundation
researchers made such strict special
containment procedures for scp-1655
something undetectable that completely
and mindlessly eliminates human
connection is extremely dangerous if
it's allowed to be left uncontained the
scp foundation researchers then began
testing on
scp-1655 saliva and the fluid it was
putting into the bloodstream of its
victims unfortunately the tests were
unable to identify all of the different
components there were however powerful
depressant chemicals and traces of
hormones found that can negatively
affect the hippocampus section of a
victim's brain the hippocampus is the
area of the brain located in the
temporal lobe it is responsible for
learning and acts as a storage unit for
memory and
scp-1655 appears to extract memories
from its victims hippocampus using these
unknown hormones causing the people
surrounding the victim to completely
detach from them could it be possible
that
scp-1655 has telepathic abilities while
physiological examinations proved unable
to confirm how
scp-1655 uses the information it
retrieves from the hippocampus to affect
others it is extremely clear that it is
actively causing mental anguish to its
subjects most likely in order to speed
up its feeding process so it's
definitely clear that
scp-1655 feeds off of the turmoil it
inflicts but the larger questions are
why and how how did
scp-1655 develop these abilities was it
evolution perhaps that is in fact the
case here or maybe it's even simpler
maybe the tick lacked a sustainable food
source and just decided to feed on
something else that was easily
accessible and just as sustainable
negativity so we have an entity that
eliminates all human bonds from the
person it attaches to then it takes the
pain and anguish a person feels from
their emotional connections disappearing
to sustain itself very dangerous stuff
here that if left to the wild could
cause unimaginable damage imagine if it
was left in a large city allowing
scp-1655 to jump from person to person
eliminating each person's emotional
connections until there is nothing left
the damage could potentially cause a
broken masquerade scenario for the scp
foundation these scenarios occur when
the scp foundation is unable to properly
contain an anomaly and thus knowledge of
the anomalous world becomes public among
their research into
scp-1655's biology yet another
interesting part of scp-16
was found it's a female specimen and has
the necessary reproductive organs while
this may seem mundane this means that
scp-1655 may have been capable of laying
eggs in the wild implying that other
members of
scp-1655 species may be out in the wild
waiting to attach itself to unknowing
humans and expand their
relationship-ruining reach further
investigation has been recommended by
the overseeing researchers the scp
foundation runs into anomalies of all
shapes sizes and danger levels some
anomalies may seem rather mundane but
pose danger when put into very specific
circumstances in the case of ticks in
general they have been responsible for
feeding on human flesh and spreading
diseases for ages but now with
scp-1655 in the game it seems that some
of the species have turned to feeding on
more than just our tangible parts
remember earlier when i mentioned that
human connection is what allowed for
humans to become the dominant species
well there's a whole lot of us humans
running around and if there are
scp-1655 species mating and spreading
among us it won't be too long until our
rain in the animal kingdom comes to a
blood-sucking end just when we thought
losing wi-fi connection was annoying
imagine losing all human connection
yikes now go check out
scp-2031 ant farm and reconstructive
maggots scp-726 for more anomalies of
the creepy crawly nature from scp
explained